Ces bobines de film
ont disparu pendant des décennies.
Personne n'a deviné
que le commandant en second d'Hitler
avait une passion secrète.
Films de sa collection privée
montrez-le dans son rôle préféré.
A l'apogée de sa puissance
au milieu des masses en liesse.
La réception d'Hermann Goering
en Autriche en mai '38.
Pendant longtemps,
il était le plus proche confident d'Hitler.
En tant que commandant en chef de la Luftwaffe,
Goering a créé une arme puissante.
Hitler et Goering,
leurs carrières étaient étroitement liées.
Jusqu'où suivent-ils un chemin commun ?
Que révèlent ces films
sur le personnage le plus flamboyant
dans le national-socialisme ?
Schorfheide, au nord de Berlin,
idéalement situé
entre lacs et forêts,
la résidence aux allures de château de Goering,
se tenait autrefois ici.
Carinhall.
La résidence d'un homme
qui a dit de lui-même,
Je suis en effet un homme de la Renaissance,
J'aime la splendeur.
Il veut être le visage jovial
de la dictature.
Cependant, Hermann Goering,
Maréchal du Troisième Reich,
était impliqué dans tout
dont le régime était responsable.
Élimination des opposants politiques.
Crimes millionnaires.
Une guerre mondiale meurtrière.
Carinhall, du nom de sa première femme,
était le symbole d'une brillante carrière.
Le pavillon de chasse autrefois modeste
devient un grand domaine,
que le fier seigneur du manoir
filmé avec sa propre caméra.
Pendant la guerre, alors que les défaites augmentaient
et villes allemandes
tombé sous une grêle de bombes,
c'était ici
qu'il se retirait de plus en plus souvent
dans un monde privé loin de la réalité.
Il regarde des films comme ça
dans son home cinéma.
La population
souffrir sous les bombardements.
Les immenses pertes de la Luftwaffe.
Les millions de victimes
tous dont les promesses non tenues,
de telles images distraient.
Au moins on a bien vécu 12 ans,
dira-t-il plus tard.
En 1945, après la mort d'Hitler,
Goering, prisonnier de guerre
est le nazi vivant le plus haut gradé.
Il est emmené dans un camp
pour les criminels de guerre allemands
qui doivent être jugés
devant un tribunal allié.
Il ne reconnaîtra jamais
sa responsabilité,
pas même aux procès de Nuremberg.
Vous devez plaider coupable ou non coupable.
"Je plaide non coupable."
À la fin, il prend la loi
dans ses propres mains avec du poison.
C'était le dernier mouvement inattendu
dans une carrière étonnante.
Hermann Wilhelm Goering,
le fils d'un ancien fonctionnaire colonial
grandit dans un vieux château de chevalier
dans la Franconie sud-allemande.
Il appartient à son parrain juif
avec qui sa mère a une liaison.
Goering est considéré comme un enfant difficile
et sa mère
prophétise qu'il deviendra
"soit un homme influent
ou un grand criminel."
Si tu veux comprendre mon frère,
dit sa sœur, Paula,
vous devez vous rendre au château de Veldenstein,
où il a passé sa jeunesse romanesque
lire les sagas
et jouer aux chevaliers, jour après jour.
Déjà enfant, Goering
passionné par tout ce qui touche à l'armée.
S'il y a une guerre, dit-il, je vais certainement
faire honneur au nom de Goering.
Pendant la Première Guerre mondiale,
il a eu sa première expérience de combat
comme jeune soldat en Alsace.
Il est blessé et fait de nouveaux plans
dans un hôpital militaire.
Le sous-lieutenant Goering vise haut.
Il veut être pilote militaire
et un héros de guerre.
Il peut signaler
l'abattage de 22 avions.
Du Kaiser lui-même,
il reçoit la plus haute distinction prussienne,
Pour Le Mérite.
En tant que dernier commandant du légendaire
Escadron de chasse Richthofen,
il devient connu dans tout le pays.
Cependant, la défaite met fin
à sa carrière époustouflante.
Son monde s'effondre.
Après la guerre, l'Allemagne
n'est plus autorisé une armée de l'air,
mais Goering veut continuer à voler
et va en Suède
devenir pilote de taxi aérien.
Un jour,
l'explorateur, le comte Eric von Rosen,
apporte Goering
dans son château de Rockelstad.
Cette visite change sa vie.
Il rencontre Carin, qui sera sa première épouse.
Elle laisse son mari et ses enfants
et épouse Goering,
le pilote de chasse de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Un scandale pour la société de l'époque.
Après la mort de Carin en 1931,
Goering cultive sa mémoire.
Il donne son nom à ses yachts.
Il y a des peintures d'elle
et même une chambre à sa mémoire.
Goering a un penchant
pour la mythologie nordique.
Il nomma sa retraite à Schorfheide,
Carinhall.
Cela ressemble à Valhalla,
l'au-delà pour les guerriers tués
qui se sont battus courageusement au combat.
Plus tard, Goering aura
les restes de sa femme enlevés
de la Suède à Carinhall.
Peu de temps après leur mariage en 1922,
ils ont déménagé à Munich,
où le national-socialiste
Parti des travailleurs allemands
commence à se faire un nom.
Face à face avec Hitler
pour la première fois,
Goering, comme il le dit lui-même,
est complètement captivé.
Hitler nomme Goering commandant
des propres troupes militaires du parti,
la SA,
disant un héros de guerre avec un Pour le Mérite,
excellente propagande.
Lors d'un putsch à Munich en novembre 1923,
Hitler tente de prendre le pouvoir.
Cependant, la police bavaroise
ouvrir le feu sur les partisans d'Hitler
devant la Feldherrnhalle.
Goering est grièvement blessé.
Les médecins lui donnent de la morphine
pour soulager la douleur.
Commence alors une toxicomanie à vie.
En 1924, Hermann et Carin Goering
voyage à Venise.
A la demande d'Hitler,
qui était en prison,
Goering demandera à Mussolini,
Le leader fasciste italien, pour de l'argent.
Goering est sur une liste des personnes recherchées.
Il a besoin de plusieurs injections
de morphine par jour.
C'est un homme sans perspective.
Pendant toute une année,
Goering a essayé d'arranger
une rencontre avec Mussolini.
Cependant, il n'a aucun intérêt
en rencontrant le messager d'un chef
dont le parti est au plus bas en Allemagne.
La mission de Goering est un échec.
Il retourne en Suède dans la famille de Carin.
Un échec politique
marqué par la toxicomanie,
il a atteint son point le plus bas.
Le médecin dans un hôpital psychiatrique
le décrit comme suicidaire, dépressif,
égocentrique, un haineux des Juifs.
Sorti de prison en Allemagne,
Hitler se prépare à accéder au pouvoir
par d'autres moyens.
Goering est déterminé à s'impliquer.
Il est de retour en Allemagne en 1927,
apparemment restauré à la santé,
déterminé à provoquer la chute
de la République de Weimar aux côtés d'Hitler.
L'ambiance politique est chargée.
La crise économique mondiale
suscite des craintes pour l'avenir
et le chômage de masse.
Les partisans d'Hitler
et les communistes se battent dans les rues.
Hitler nomme Goering,
son plénipotentiaire à Berlin,
parce que le héros de guerre hautement décoré
a d'excellents contacts
à l'aristocratie
et le monde de la haute finance.
En 1932, les nazis deviennent
le parti le plus puissant du Reichstag,
et Goering, président.
Qu'Hitler est capable de prendre le pouvoir
est également dû à son aide, Goering.
En tant que ministre de l'Intérieur en Prusse,
Goering commence immédiatement
pour réprimer les opposants politiques.
Peu de temps après,
le Reichstag brûle.
Les causes de l'incendie sont contestées,
même si les conséquences sont décisives.
Les droits fondamentaux sont suspendus,
et la persécution devient légale.
Les entreprises juives sont boycottées.
La SA traque
Communistes et sociaux-démocrates,
et le chantier
des camps de concentration sauvages commence.
A partir du 11 avril 1933,
Goering est ministre-président de la Prusse.
Élu à cette haute fonction
à la majorité des représentants
du peuple allemand
et en tant que candidat
du parti le plus fort,
Je suis déterminé à diriger ce bureau
pour le plus grand profit
du peuple allemand.
Avant tout, je suis déterminé
restaurer ce parlement
à son ancien état de dignité,
tel que conçu
par notre ancien grand homme d'État, Bismarck.
Goering a fondé la Gestapo,
la police secrète,
et il assume un rôle clé
dans l'établissement de la dictature.
Il ne tolérera aucune concurrence.
La SA commence à faire des demandes de pouvoir.
Avec le commandant SS Himmler,
Goering planifie une intrigue
contre la direction des troupes du parti.
Ces images
ont été prises le 23 mai 1934,
à Golzheimer Heide près de Düsseldorf.
Goering commémore
Albert Léo Schlageter,
un membre de l'allemand
troupes de résistance paramilitaires
fusillé par les Français en 1923.
Juste un mois plus tard,
dans la Nuit des Longs Couteaux,
200 personnes sont assassinées,
y compris tous les membres éminents
de la SA et leur chef, Ernst Röhm.
Goering se retire dans sa maison
à Obersalzberg
à proximité d'Hitler.
Le dictateur admire
la cruauté des actions de Goering
et le nomme son successeur
s'il devait lui-même mourir.
Bonjour, César.
Vous venez me rendre visite ?
Avez-vous pris votre repas ?
Êtes-vous rassasié ?
Allez, saute.
Saute, vas-y, c'est bon.
Je n'ai pas de conscience dit Goering.
Adolf Hitler est ma conscience.
Après le meurtre de Rohm,
sa réputation à l'étranger
devient aussi mauvais que jamais.
Des caricatures le représentent
dans un putain de tablier de boucher
brandissant une hache.
Cependant,
Goering veut être vu différemment.
Il veut s'engager dans la politique étrangère
et sait qu'une telle image
rendra les choses difficiles.
Il veut être populaire,
et adoré par les masses,
comme ici en Autriche en mai 1938.
Il quitte la Gestapo et la police
entre les mains de Himmler, Heydrich,
et les SS.
Goering, commandant en second après Hitler,
veut profiter du pouvoir
et assumer un rôle représentatif.
A cet effet, Hitler
met à sa disposition un fonds spécial
et aux frais de l'état
lui fait cadeau d'une maison.
Ce qui était initialement un style suédois
modeste cabane en rondins devient Carinhall,
la splendide demeure de Schorfheide.
Ces images sont également
parmi les possessions privées de Goering.
Diplomates et visiteurs d'État
sont divertis ici.
Sa toxicomanie
l'affecte toujours beaucoup.
Son penchant pour le déguisement
et l'autoglorification
semble vraiment grotesque.
Cependant, intérieurement,
Goering reste fidèle à lui-même.
Il est interdit aux ressortissants allemands
ou d'autres personnes liées au sang
épouser des Juifs.
L'antisémitisme devient le mot de la loi.
Les lois raciales de Nuremberg
sont annoncés par Goering passant
au rassemblement du Parti en 1935.
De toutes les hautes fonctions
que Goering stocke,
l'un est d'une importance particulière
à l'ancien pilote de chasse
Ministre de l'Air du Reich,
avec pour mission de constituer une nouvelle armée de l'air.
En 1935, au rassemblement du Parti,
Goering présente l'armement,
qui a été fabriqué secrètement
au cours des dernières années.
Le traité de Versailles est ouvertement rompu
devant les yeux du monde.
À la fin de l'année,
Goering a 1 800 avions sous ses ordres.
La nouvelle force aérienne doit jouer
un rôle décisif dans la stratégie d'Hitler.
En 1936, il s'agit d'un baptême du feu
dans la guerre civile espagnole.
Goering présentant des médailles
aux soldats de la Légion Condor.
Un soldat filme la procédure.
Le bombardement
de la ville espagnole de Guernica
démontre à un monde choqué
ce dont l'armée de l'air est capable.
C'est Goering qui ouvre la voie
pour cela dans le nouveau ministère de l'air,
le centre de Berlin.
L'homme qui détient le pouvoir ici
joue également un rôle central
dans l'économie.
En 1936, Goering devient
commissaire du plan quadriennal,
et avec ça, dictateur
de l'économie et de l'armement.
C'est la volonté d'Hitler pour l'économie
être prêt pour la guerre dans quatre ans.
Jusqu'à présent, c'est sa tâche la plus importante.
Ce nouveau bureau montre à quel point
Hitler fait confiance à son commandant en second
parce que la guerre
s'est vu accorder la plus haute priorité.
Importations, matières premières, devises,
Goering contrôle presque tout
et a déjà l'œil sur le prochain objectif.
Hitler exige l'annexion de l'Autriche,
et Goering saisit l'occasion.
Utilise les menaces pour faire pression
sur le gouvernement autrichien
jusqu'à ce que le chancelier Schuschnigg démissionne,
libérant la voie à Hitler.
Le 4 avril 1938,
Le chef forestier du canton, Aurelius Meyer,
filme l'arrivée d'Hitler à Klagenfurt.
Séquences filmées privées
montre le retour d'Hitler
mis en scène comme un cortège triomphal
dans tout le pays.
L'annexion de l'Autriche
est le sommet de l'alliance
entre Hitler et Goering.
Si le dictateur exprime des doutes,
Goering les écarte et agit.
Ils se complètent.
En temps de crise,
dit Hitler, Goering fait preuve de sang-froid.
Le 15 mai 1938, Goering
se rend sur les scènes de sa jeunesse.
En tant que nationaliste de la vieille école,
s'emparer de l'Autriche était l'accomplissement
de ses rêves d'une grande Allemagne.
Ici aussi cependant,
inaperçu des caméras,
Juifs et opposants politiques
sont humiliés dans la rue
et arrêté.
Goering voyages
à Mauterndorf dans la région de Salzbourg
dans l'un des châteaux qu'il a connus enfant,
et là, célèbre la rencontre de ses sœurs,
Olga et Paula, encore.
Tous deux sont mariés à des avocats autrichiens.
Goering a senti
de belles opportunités d'affaires
lors de l'annexion de l'Autriche.
Reichswerke d'Hermann Goering,
l'un des plus grands complexes industriels
en Europe,
cherche à s'étendre vers le sud-est.
Aujourd'hui l'Autriche, porte d'entrée des Balkans,
est sous contrôle allemand.
Goering est content.
Pendant qu'il s'adonne
dans les souvenirs d'enfance,
Hitler se prépare
la prochaine étape vers la guerre.
Il envisage d'écraser la Tchécoslovaquie
et Goering doit organiser
la mobilisation économique.
Cependant, il veut empêcher une grande guerre
parce qu'il doute que cela réussisse.
Goering connaît l'économie nécessaire
et les conditions militaires font défaut.
Cependant, il n'ose pas
dire cela ouvertement.
Au contraire,
devant des représentants
de l'industrie aéronautique,
il a l'air confiant
"qu'il y aura un énorme gâchis"
"et que nous devrons partir
dans une grande guerre",
"ce que je n'hésiterais pas à faire."
L'Allemagne serait alors
la première puissance mondiale
et aurait le contrôle
des marchés mondiaux
et être un pays riche.
Cependant, nous aurions à prendre un risque,
dit Goering.
Il évite les conflits ouverts,
fait ce que veut Hitler,
et dans les coulisses
pratique la diplomatie de paix.
A Carinhall, il reçoit des diplomates
de Hongrie, de Pologne et de Grande-Bretagne.
Avant tout, Goering
veut améliorer les relations avec Londres.
Il voit l'Allemagne comme une grande puissance impériale,
mais il ne veut pas de guerre mondiale.
En septembre 38,
à la Conférence de Munich,
Goering présente le texte d'un traité
conçu pour maintenir
la paix fragile du moment.
Pour ça,
Hitler le critiquera sévèrement.
Octobre '38, les troupes allemandes
a marché dans les Sudètes
comme stipulé dans l'Accord de Munich.
Cependant, Hitler veut
plus que ce qu'il appelle des guerres de fleurs.
Novembre 38, le baptême
de la fille de Goering, Edda, à Carinhall.
A ses côtés, sa nouvelle épouse, Emmy Sonnemann.
La relation entre Hitler
et Goering est troublé.
Pour la première fois,
le dictateur parle de lui comme d'un lâche.
Mars '39.
Alors qu'Hitler
entre en Tchécoslovaquie,
Goering est en vacances en Italie.
Tout d'un coup, il a perdu son influence.
Hitler a maintenant d'autres conseillers.
Joachim de Ribbentrop
pour les affaires étrangères.
Goering sent que la guerre est inévitable,
bien qu'il n'ose pas
contredire ouvertement.
Chaque fois que je me tiens devant le Führer,
dit-il, mon cœur coule dans mes bottes.
Ces images
des archives privées de Goering
ont été prises lors d'un spectacle aérien
sur l'île d'Usedom.
Ernst Udet, responsable
pour renforcer les forces aériennes,
hors de sa profondeur.
Il doit se suicider en novembre 41.
De nouveaux types d'avions sont présentés.
Goering assure Hitler
que la Luftwaffe est prête pour la guerre.
Aux commandes de l'économie et des armements,
personne ne peut mieux juger que Goering
si le Reich est vraiment capable
de mener une grande guerre.
Cependant, il supprime la réalité
et se laisse impressionner
par 4 000 des avions les plus modernes
et de nombreux escadrons de chasse améliorés.
À l'été 1939,
il y a 400 000 en service
pour la Luftwaffe.
Les quatre flottes aéroportées
semblent parfaitement équipés
pour une longue guerre.
L'épée émoussée a été aiguisée
au cours des quatre dernières années.
Même si en comparaison
aux forces aériennes d'autres pays,
il y a un manque de bombes et de carburant.
Le commandant en chef Goering essaie toujours
pour empêcher la guerre qui menace.
6 juin 1939 à Berlin.
La capitale est décorée
pour l'accueil de la Légion Condor.
Nous sommes à la veille de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
"Nous devrions arrêter de jouer au poker"
Goering plaide presque Hitler.
La réponse était,
"J'ai toujours joué au poker."
En Espagne, 5 000 soldats allemands
a aidé Franco à la victoire
dans sa tentative de pouvoir.
Un galop d'essai sans trop de pertes.
Maintenant quelque chose de bien plus
dimension terrible menace.
Goering tient des pourparlers secrets avec l'Angleterre.
Il veut préserver la paix
et continuer à vivre
une vie de luxe et de splendeur,
comme un homme de la Renaissance.
Il a beaucoup à perdre.
L'attaque contre la Pologne
commence le 1er septembre 1939.
La Luftwaffe de Goering prend le contrôle
du ciel presque sans effort.
Les Polonais n'ont aucune chance.
Bombardiers en piqué
avec des sirènes assourdissantes dégagent le chemin
pour l'attaque des forces terrestres.
Goering est dévoué à Hitler
car il lui doit tout.
Des films privés le montrent à l'ouverture
de la relève hivernale d'octobre 1939.
Ses tentatives en demi-teinte
influencer Hitler n'a servi à rien.
Goering reste obéissant.
C'est lui qui commande
la dépossession de tous les Juifs polonais.
Les occupants allemands créent des ghettos
comme celui-ci ici à Litzmannstadt,
le Lodz d'aujourd'hui,
où les Juifs vivent dans des conditions épouvantables.
Bientôt, les ghettos ne sont plus que des intermédiaires
s'arrête avant l'expulsion
aux camps d'extermination.
Goering est également impliqué dans cette guerre.
En novembre 1938,
quand les synagogues brûlent,
c'est Goering qui décide
que la population juive d'Allemagne
ne pas payer un milliard de reichsmark
comme "expiation", comme il dit.
Les Juifs doivent être dépossédés
et contraint à l'exil.
Goering, cependant,
prend grand soin de s'assurer que son nom
n'est pas associé aux crimes.
Dans la campagne française, la Luftwaffe
montre des signes distincts de faiblesse.
Le corps expéditionnaire britannique
s'est retiré à Dunkerque
sur la côte de la Manche.
Goering promet que ses avions
détruira les troupes alliées,
mais les choses se passent différemment.
Trois cent trente-huit mille
Soldats britanniques, français et belges
réussi à fuir.
Si Goering avait pu tenir parole,
il y aurait eu peu de chance
d'Angleterre empêchant une invasion allemande.
Deux semaines auparavant, Rotterdam
avait été durement touché par la Luftwaffe.
Alors que les négociations
car la reddition de la Hollande avait lieu,
Les avions de Goering rasés
la ville sans défense au sol.
L'actualité des négociations
avait atteint le commandement allemand trop tard.
La campagne sur le front occidental
s'était terminé rapidement de façon inattendue.
Récompenses hitlériennes
le commandant suprême victorieux
le bâton du Maréchal.
Goering seul fait un peu mieux.
Un titre est créé spécialement pour lui,
Maréchal du Reich.
Il est l'officier le plus haut gradé
dans l'armée allemande
et a une résidence, Carinhall,
qui devient de plus en plus splendide.
Un manoir plein de trésors d'art
De partout dans le monde.
Goering collectionne les maîtres anciens,
tapisseries et sculptures.
Il n'y a pas moyen de le retenir
quand il est mort sur un objet.
Pour lui, la défaite de la France
signifie de riches opportunités de pillage.
Paris regorge d'art,
et l'homme
qui est le commandant en second dans l'état
vient prendre ce qu'il veut.
Le Louvre, sacré pour tout amateur d'art.
Pour Goering, rien de plus que
un grand magasin libre-service d'art.
Sur sa liste de courses,
de grands noms comme Rubens, Velasquez,
Cranach le Jeune,
et Cranach l'Ancien.
Que beaucoup de peintures ont été
en possession juive peu de temps auparavant,
est sans conséquence.
Goering, le collectionneur,
ne négocie pas.
Dans la plupart des cas,
lui seul détermine le prix.
Puis il fait ses courses
chargé dans un train spécial
être amené à Carinhall.
Il y a quelque chose de addictif dans la façon
il collectionne pour son musée Hermann Goering
ériger un mémorial à lui-même.
Les experts recherchent partout
dans les pays occupés
pour les trésors d'art
pour la collection Goering.
Tout propriétaire refusant de coopérer
met sa vie en danger.
Suite de la campagne
sur le front occidental,
la Luftwaffe a des bases
aux Pays-Bas, en Belgique,
et le nord de la France.
Les îles britanniques sont à portée de main.
Hitler veut envahir l'Angleterre
et la Luftwaffe de Goering
est d'atteindre la suprématie aérienne
et bombarder l'île pour la soumettre.
Goering croit que ses avions
peut détruire la Royal Air Force
en seulement cinq semaines.
Visite d'une base aérienne en France
à l'été 1940,
avec l'ancien camarade de la Première Guerre mondiale de Goering,
Bruno Loerzer,
un général de l'armée de l'air à gauche de Goering.
Ils se sont connus
depuis septembre 1914.
Les rapports saisissants de Loerzer sur la guerre aérienne
attiré Goering
à la Luftwaffe à l'époque.
Maintenant en 1940, dit Goering
Loerzer est son général le plus paresseux.
Néanmoins, il le laisse être,
parce que, comme le dit Goering,
J'ai besoin de quelqu'un pour boire une bouteille
de vin rouge avec le soir.
La bataille d'Angleterre
sera sa première défaite sérieuse.
La Royal Air Force
est égal à la Luftwaffe.
Les Spitfire britanniques infligent de lourdes pertes.
Fin septembre 1940,
prévoit d'envahir
sont mis de côté indéfiniment.
Le commandant en chef de la Luftwaffe
se retire de la vue du public.
D'octobre 1940 à janvier 1941,
Goering est en vacances
sur les lacs de Carinhall.
Même à la hauteur
de la bataille pour l'air,
il ne renonce pas
aller chasser en Prusse orientale,
car en attendant,
il est devenu le maître impérial de la chasse,
Jagermeister du Reich.
Les erreurs dans la construction
et planification de la Luftwaffe
sont d'une évidence flagrante,
mais Goering blâme les autres.
Il est au milieu d'une guerre
dont il ne voulait pas,
mais qu'il est pourtant
parier avec toutes les conséquences.
Le 22 juin 1941.
Avec l'attaque contre l'Union soviétique,
la guerre d'anéantissement
exigée par Hitler commence.
Goering est bien informé
sur les fusillades de civils
derrière la ligne de front.
Qui plus est, au printemps 41,
il a donné Reinhard Heydrich,
chef du service de sécurité SS,
commandes à rédiger
un ensemble de lignes directrices pour les troupes
sur qui mettre devant un peloton d'exécution.
Surtout, les officiers politiques et les juifs.
Des millions de prisonniers soviétiques
perdre la vie dans cette guerre.
Dans la capitale, Berlin, Goering,
en tant que commandant en second d'Hitler,
a un pouvoir presque illimité.
En juillet 41, victoire sur l'Union soviétique
semble à portée de main.
Reinhard Heidrich,
dont les troupes spéciales sur le front de l'Est
tirer des milliers chaque jour
comme Goering lui donne des pouvoirs étendus.
Goering ordonne à Heydrich de préparer la voie
pour "la solution finale
de la question juive"
dans les zones d'influence allemande en Europe.
Partout en Allemagne,
les déportations commencent.
Ces enregistrements de films privés
montrer les 293 derniers Juifs de Dresde
être chargé dans un train
début mars 1942.
La destination est la rampe
au camp d'extermination
à Auschwitz Birkenau.
Seuls dix auraient survécu.
La signature de Goering est une étape supplémentaire
vers le meurtre organisé.
Cependant, officiellement,
il ne veut rien avoir à faire
avec les crimes du tout.
La Luftwaffe
n'est pas préparé pour cette guerre.
Son système de défense est chaotique.
Même des ingénieurs comme Willy Messerschmitt
ne peut pas résoudre le problème central.
Il n'y a pas assez d'avions
et trop peu de moteurs puissants.
Outre les militaires,
ces planeurs transportent également
matériel militaire léger,
et ils ont joué un rôle important
dans la bataille de Crète.
Autres nouveaux développements technologiques
arrivent trop tard ou ne servent à rien.
Ernst Udet est responsable
pour le désastre de la défense.
Il se décompose
sous le poids de la responsabilité
et prend sa propre vie.
Décisions préliminaires
sont faites sur le front de l'Est.
L'attaque contre Moscou échoue.
Une armée entière tombe à Stalingrad.
Goering avait promis une livraison quotidienne
de 500 tonnes de ravitaillement par voie aérienne.
Seulement une fraction
de cela atteint les troupes encerclées.
Sa position avec Hitler
tombe à son point le plus bas.
Nuit après nuit,
Les bombardiers britanniques effectuent
attaques dévastatrices contre des villes allemandes.
Il mangerait son chapeau si un avion ennemi
jamais atteint le Reich, dit Goering.
Sa Luftwaffe est impuissante.
Les unités anti-aériennes
ne peut qu'obstruer le flot des bombardiers,
pas les arrêter.
Goering est également responsable
pour la défense aérienne.
L'Association de défense aérienne du Reich,
avec ses millions de membres,
vient sous son commandement.
Enregistrements de films privés
à partir de mars 1943.
Unités de police de défense anti-aérienne exerçant
un exercice d'urgence dans le centre de Berlin.
La plus grande inquiétude concerne les attaques au gaz.
Jeunes et adultes
porter le soi-disant masque à gaz du peuple.
Les gens pensent qu'ils sont bien équipés
pour les prochains attentats.
Personne n'a d'idée
du pouvoir dévastateur
d'explosifs brisants et de bombes incendiaires.
Comme à Hambourg, en juillet 43.
Un incendie a pris d'assaut les rues, détruisant
grandes parties de la ville hanséatique.
Les températures atteignent jusqu'à 1 000 degrés.
Plus de 40 000 personnes meurent.
Comment Goering va-t-il réagir
à une telle catastrophe ?
Il semble imperturbable et léthargique.
Il ne prend aucune décision.
Tout au plus distribue-t-il des médailles.
Sa Luftwaffe ne peut pas s'arrêter
les attaques alliées.
Développements techniques
comme un radar aéroporté,
un sens dit de Lichtenstein,
apporter des avantages à court terme
à la guerre aérienne.
Cependant, les Britanniques trouvent
un moyen de parer les attaques,
aveuglant le radar
avec des bandes de papier d'aluminium.
C'était un facteur crucial
dans l'attaque de Hambourg.
Les attaques sont aussi dirigées
auprès de la population civile,
destiné à les démoraliser.
L'Allemagne sous un attentat à la bombe.
Images non censurées
jamais diffusé dans les actualités de l'époque.
Suprématie aérienne sur le front de l'Est
est perdu depuis longtemps,
pendant que Goering
tient un tribunal à Carinhall
et s'exhibant
ses dernières acquisitions artistiques.
Le commandant en chef
ne veut pas voir de telles images.
Il est aliéné de ses troupes.
La chasse l'intéresse plus que tout.
Avec son appareil photo,
il enregistre quoi
lui semble plus important
que les pertes élevées de ses pilotes
ou les villes qui tombent.
Cerfs sur son terrain de chasse privé.
Depuis le printemps 1944, l'US Air Force
avait le contrôle de l'air sur l'Allemagne.
Les avions de chasse de Goering ne peuvent pas faire grand-chose
contre cette force supérieure.
Il manque de tout,
moteurs, essence, pilotes.
Surtout un manque
de décisions claires venant d'en haut.
Le bombardement
atteint son paroxysme destructeur.
Jusqu'à présent,
Le Berghof d'Hitler échappe aux attentats.
Le chef de guerre est outragé
par la défaite de la Luftwaffe
et les promesses vides
de son successeur désigné.
En mai 44,
Les forces américaines bombardent l'industrie du carburant.
La colonne vertébrale
de l'industrie de guerre allemande est en panne.
Itinéraires de transport
sont systématiquement détruits.
Quand les Alliés débarquent
en Normandie le 6 juin 44,
la Luftwaffe allemande ne joue aucun rôle.
Il a été vaincu.
L'ampleur des pertes est catastrophique.
Rien qu'en novembre 44,
404 avions de chasse sont perdus
et 244 pilotes tués.
Une arme miracle
aurait pu renverser la vapeur.
Le plus grand et le seul espoir
de reconquérir la suprématie aérienne
réside dans le chasseur à réaction Me 262.
Mille quatre cents de ces jets
sont livrés à l'armée de l'air,
mais plus de 200 ne quittent jamais le sol.
Cependant, même le plus grand nombre de jets
aurait été impuissant
contre la force supérieure
de la flotte de bombardiers.
Adolf Galland, général de la Luftwaffe,
est connu pour appeler un chat un chat.
Encore et encore, il attire l'attention
à l'infériorité matérielle sans espoir
de leurs armes.
Cependant,
Goering ne souffre d'aucune critique.
Galland tombe en disgrâce.
Il deviendra le bouc émissaire
responsable de l'effondrement
de la Luftwaffe.
Fin janvier 45,
il est remplacé comme général de la Luftwaffe.
La bataille pour la suprématie aérienne
sur l'Allemagne est terminée.
pilotes allemands,
toujours plus jeune et mal formé,
sont envoyés en mission suicide.
A la fin de la guerre,
Goering se retire à Berchtesgaden.
À Berlin,
l'armée rouge se bat
vers le bunker d'Hitler dans le centre-ville.
Dans un message radio, Goering annonce
qu'il prendra le gouvernement
si Hitler ne prend pas contact.
Le commandant en second pense
que son heure de successeur est venue.
A Berlin cependant, Hitler sent la trahison
et ordonne aux SS
pour arrêter Goering dans sa maison.
Il est démis de toutes ses fonctions.
Comme l'armée américaine
s'approche d'Obersalzberg,
les SS amènent Goering
à Mauterndorf en Autriche
dans l'un des châteaux de son enfance.
Après le suicide d'Hitler,
il envisage de négocier
avec le général américain Eisenhower.
Il croit encore
qu'il ne peut pas être contourné.
Le 7 mai 1945, Hermann Goering
devient volontairement un prisonnier américain,
croire à tort
que les vainqueurs négocieront avec lui
comme émissaire allemand.
Les IG surprises
saisir les armes, les médailles,
et la bague émeraude
de l'ancien Maréchal du Reich.
Sa femme, Emmy, et Edda, sa fille
sont faits prisonniers par des soldats américains.
Malgré l'arrestation,
La confiance en soi de Goering est intacte.
Il tient une conférence de presse.
Admettra-t-il sa culpabilité ?
Il n'avait aucune idée
sur ce qui se passait
dans les camps de concentration, dit Goering.
C'est tout ce que fait Himmler.
Lui, en tant que maréchal du Reich,
n'aurait jamais permis
de telles atrocités.
Pas une trace de remords.
N'importe qui de n'importe quel niveau
dans la Luftwaffe de Goering
est maintenant prisonnier de guerre.
Adolf Galland,
parler boutique avec des pilotes américains.
Maréchal Kesselring,
jusqu'à récemment commandant en chef
sur le front occidental.
Hans-Ulrich Rudel, pas de pilote allemand
a effectué autant de sorties que lui, 2 350.
Hermann Göring
semble en effet surpris
se trouver
sur la liste des criminels de guerre.
Un journaliste américain rapporte
de la conférence de presse de Goering.
Le grand homme se sentait plutôt mal à l'aise.
Il transpirait
comme il a demandé au traducteur de souligner
qu'à cause d'une querelle,
lui, le Maréchal du Reich,
n'avait pas été en bons termes
longtemps avec le Führer.
Complètement au secret,
insista-t-il en agitant le doigt.
Merci de le souligner,
c'est important, dit-il.
Goering, le nazi vivant le plus haut gradé,
est amené à Nuremberg.
Dans la ville
où se tenaient autrefois les rassemblements du Parti
et maintenant dévasté par des tapis de bombes,
les criminels de guerre les plus importants
doivent être jugés par un tribunal allié.
Nuremberg
avait été pointé du doigt pour des attaques aériennes
et était un désert de ruines.
Cependant, le seul bâtiment
qui s'est échappé est le tribunal,
la scène des procès de Nuremberg
des grands criminels de guerre.
Les prisonniers sont détenus dans ces cellules.
L'homme que les Alliés appellent
Numéro un nazi
est également surveillé jour et nuit.
Goering, qui jusqu'à récemment
avalé des dizaines de pilules,
est hors de la drogue et au régime.
Le 25 novembre '45,
Goering entre dans la salle d'audience.
Pour la première fois dans l'histoire,
politiciens et militaires
sont tenus responsables
pour leurs crimes devant un tribunal.
Les torts que nous cherchons
condamner et punir
ont été tellement calculés,
si malin et si dévastateur
cette civilisation
ne peut tolérer qu'on les ignore
parce qu'il ne peut pas survivre
leur répétition.
Goering s'attend à la peine de mort.
Il est totalement sans remords.
L'homme autrefois le plus puissant,
à côté d'Hitler,
prétend ne rien savoir
sur les millions de crimes.
Je n'ai jamais exprimé mon accord
avec l'idée qu'une race peut être dite
être la race maîtresse sur toutes les autres.
Au contraire, j'ai toujours insisté
les différences dans les races.
Lors du contre-interrogatoire,
le procureur en chef américain,
Robert Jackson,
essaie de coincer l'accusé,
mais avec Goering,
cela mène toujours à une impasse.
C'est vrai, n'est-ce pas ?
j'ai déjà répondu
que très clairement,
mais ces explications
appartiennent à ce qui a déjà été dit.
Votre avocat y veillera.
Confiant et verbeux,
Goering joue une dernière fois à la galerie
et accuse les Alliés d'avoir fait
les mêmes choses que les nazis.
Son objectif est de partir
une image positive de lui-même pour la postérité.
Cependant, le poids
des preuves est énorme.
Les procureurs soviétiques montrent
un film qui détruit toutes les illusions.
Auschwitz.
Le crime le plus épouvantable
jamais contre l'humanité.
Entre autres,
c'est Goering qui est responsable.
Il est reconnu coupable de tous les actes d'accusation
et condamné à mort.
Jusqu'à la fin amère,
il ne montre aucun signe de remords.
Toutes ces choses étaient des choses nécessaires,
comme je t'ai compris,
protéger…
Oui, ces choses étaient nécessaires
à cause de ce à quoi nous étions confrontés.
Le jugement
ne l'affecte en rien,
Goering a dit
le psychologue judiciaire américain.
L'exécution doit avoir lieu
le 16 octobre 1946.
Il planifie son dernier coup
et écrit une lettre
au commandant des prisonniers.
Il avait trois gélules
de poison en sa possession
quand il a été emmené en prison.
j'ai mis le premier
dans mes vêtements pour qu'on le retrouve
quand j'ai été fouillé.
J'ai si bien frappé le deuxième
dans ma cellule qu'il était introuvable
malgré les fréquents
et des recherches approfondies.
je l'avais avec moi
aux audiences du tribunal dans mes bottes.
La troisième capsule
était dans ma petite trousse de toilette
dans un pot rond de crème pour la peau.
C'était carrément impossible à trouver.
Cette capsule cachée de poison
était le dernier secret de Goering.
Un autre secret
est découvert à Berchtesgaden
peu après la fin de la guerre.
Troupes américaines
atteindre les ruines du Berghof d'Hitler
et la maison de campagne de Goering
à proximité immédiate.
Le guide de montagne de Goering se lie d'amitié avec un GI
et lui donne des pellicules
de la propriété privée de Goering
comme souvenir.
Depuis des décennies,
ils ont ramassé la poussière dans une cave aux États-Unis
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient retrouvés
et soigneusement restauré.
Les films privés de Goering montrent des scènes clés
dans la vie de l'homme le plus puissant
après Hitler dans la dictature NS.
Le plus proche confident d'Hitler.
Le visage jovial du régime.
Un homme aux multiples visages.
Carinhall,
sa résidence aux allures de château près de Berlin,
a été explosé
durant les derniers jours de la guerre.
Avant cela,
les trésors d'art ont été mis en sécurité
puis plus tard confisqué par l'armée américaine.
Troupes de déblaiement,
dans une tentative d'effacer l'histoire,
mais il reste toujours des traces.